[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday yeah and happy
day before fourth of july yeah we're
going to the club tonight too yeah it's
not going to be it's not going to be a
serious night though they got weak
drinks there
it'll be okay
yeah yeah we'll just go there i mean you
know we had a good time friday night too
but yeah so it looks like people are
still
starting to come in i got a story about
this movie yeah this this is pretty good
this movie called beast within the beast
with this
yeah
and i was always getting it confused
with another movie called extro
and i saw this when i was a kid
all right it's my freshman year of high
school i had just moved to brazil
all right
and
the
the kid that lived in the apartment
underneath me
his name was nelson augusto
he was a brazilian kid but he went to a
british private school
there in brazil
so he spoke english and just by chance
he lived right under youtube
so i'm new to brazil and i started
hanging out with this brazilian guy
we're listening to [ __ ] heavy metal
and [ __ ] and he's a total stoner
we got a high [ __ ] and [ __ ] watch
this movie
and the movie is taking place in
mississippi yeah i don't know what i
mean i'm like wait a minute i'm i'm in
brazil and it's taking me back to
mississippi now you know
and it and [ __ ]
it's about a kid about a teenage kid
who i didn't i couldn't i couldn't
remember the story
real well you know i mean as an adult
i knew it was about a teenage kid that
was transforming into what i thought was
an alien
and i didn't really catch it
when i first watched a movie probably
because i was high
the kid actually is turning into the
most mississippi [ __ ] monster you
could ever [ __ ] think of he's turning
it into a [ __ ] cicada
aware cicada yeah
and it happened because his mom got
raped by cicada
ever cicada monster
and
i didn't pick it up in first viewing but
second viewing seeing this thing again
this is the first of all this
[ __ ] is a masterpiece
[Laughter]
the reason why
the reason why
mom got raped by a dab of cicada man
that dude
was fooling around on another with
another dude's wife
and that guy captured him and put him
underneath the house
and was feeding him dead bodies
as one does as one does
because this is happening in mississippi
we've all been there right yeah
and the dude has gotten captured as the
uh cousin to the local judge and they
run the town
so they're able to [ __ ] instead of
bury the bodies out of the cemetery
they're giving it to this dude making
him eat it which of course is going to
turn you into cicada man
i never really explained i thought
everybody knew that only in the
mississippi
only in the mississippi verse does that
happen
all right
and this [ __ ] here man
it affected me man it had good [ __ ]
uh
uh special effects for the day
that's really i think the main i mean
the other this this has like a really
stacked cast as well like pretty much
everybody that's in it you will
recognize which i'll get into in a bit
but i think like the best thing about
this other than it's utterly batshit
insane premise
is the special effects are actually
quite quite good this was 82 this came
out and the acting isn't bad um and it's
shot competently and it's filmed in
mississippi this is a mississippi
[ __ ] movie
and had you known mississippi in the 70s
and the early 80s when this movie
you know it was supposed to actually the
movie starts and it's supposed to be in
the 60s
but if you ever went to mississippi in
the 50 you know anytime before that 90s
mississippi was a [ __ ] swarm of
insects
24 7. just [ __ ] bugs everywhere
especially at night
every damn light had a [ __ ] cloud of
bugs swirling around it
they had bug zappers there's blue lights
on them and you can sit there and just
[ __ ] i don't know why we did it
everybody seemed to had to have one
just sapping bugs all [ __ ] night long
and all the frogs underneath the bug zap
are eating all the [ __ ] dead bugs
it's just funny you know i mean
you weren't even putting a dent in the
population it was just
it attracted bugs and killed them
but it's not like that anymore it's
funny you don't
isn't that funny how the swarms of
insects are gone i don't know because
maybe the population is more dense so
they you're dividing up the bugs between
the lights now i don't know yeah it
could be or you know there might be like
a combination of factors maybe it's like
other species were introduced that eat
more of that insecticide or something
yeah insecticides i'm sure that has
something to do with it too so every
time i was every every time i was going
to the south you know there was always
like [ __ ] cicada years sometimes the
years are really [ __ ] bad if you guys
know what a cicada is it's a flying bug
with the wings folded back on it it's
that long it's like that big around it's
the size of a dam
it's the size of a turd and it looks
like a turd looks like a green turd with
eyes on it
with [ __ ] legs and a face
all right it looks like something out of
the outer limits remember like the zin
what they call the zindy attack now what
was that
the zindy misfits the zante misfits
remember that
episode where they got attacked by the
giant ants
from outer space on the outer limits you
don't remember that one no i don't yeah
they look like that
and that's what happens in this movie
dude turns into a [ __ ] giant one and
it's waking people kind of and killing
people kind of it's he doesn't really
look like a bug no that's i'm kind of
gonna say his head does for a minute
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay
he kind of i mean he kind of looked like
um my little brother when he got the
sunstroke one year and his face
ballooned it kind of looks like that
like a much more extreme version
obviously it's got the dude that played
koh hagan from um total recall those are
the guy who played the head of ocp
robocop it's got him yeah ronnie cox and
his wife
is that hottie that played
kirk's girlfriend from wrath of khan the
one where you know the son got killed
later
yeah bibi's her real name but she played
that doctor she's in it
it's got every
character actor that hollywood has is in
this [ __ ] movie that was inches in
the 80s yeah you were just kind of like
oh my god exactly every single person
was recognizable every one of them
except except the kid that turned into
the damn
monster
he's only in a few movies he's
weird-looking though he looks like a a
teenage male chrissy hines
well i mean i think that maybe like
contributed because yeah he's kind of
like not ugly but he was just like
looking weird-looking he was just like
odd-looking
i don't know if those were real teeth or
not he just had these [ __ ]
weird-looking teeth and he was making
weird grimaces and looking really
[ __ ] creepy in it
he did a good job in it i thought he did
too yeah
but it was weird movie yeah i mean i
remembered it yeah the thing about it
okay so last night
we were i was just like scrolling
through and i was on hbo max and i was
like well i was like we need to watch
two movies because we're going out
tonight and we won't have time to watch
a movie so i said we need two like one
to talk about today and want to talk
about tomorrow so actually the first one
we watched i was like oh they have
amityville 2 the possession yeah so we
watched that one
so we'll talk about that one tomorrow
probably
and then we were either going to watch
amityville 3 but then for whatever
reason tom was like oh i remember this
movie that i saw when i was a kid and it
scared the [ __ ] out of me um he's like
but i was really high when i watched it
yeah and he said it was the beast within
and i kind of looked at him i was like i
don't think i've ever seen that i think
i've seen like
scenes of it like the scenes like the
special effects of like the
transformation and stuff which is quite
good
but i had never seen the movie and i was
like well you know so let's watch that
one so we like rented it i think it's on
amazon prime or something and then when
we started watching it
i discovered
that not only was this directed by
philippe mora who's the same guy that
directed communion which we just talked
about like with christopher walken yeah
and he also did howling to your sister's
werewolf which is an awful movie in
howling three so he did those as well
but this was actually the first feature
film writing credit
for horror legend
tom holland the guy that did
uh fright night the guy that did a
child's play
um yeah that guy uh finner psycho two
um yeah he did all of those and this was
his first writing credit so
what ended up happening with this book
okay or with this movie is that it's
based on a book sort of
this is an unfinished book yeah kinda i
don't i don't know if it was like was it
ever finished no i thought they said
they bought and on the rights to an
unfinished book well they did but i
think he finished it later okay so the
guy's name was edward levy that wrote
the novel
and
the rights were bought to it
but it wasn't done like when they
because i guess like the author was
having some kind of marital difficulties
or something and he couldn't like finish
the book like for the time that the
pre-production started so tom holland
was like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna like
take what's written and then i'll just
do my own thing
now i haven't read the novel but i read
the wikipedia synopsis
i don't think there's anything about
cicadas in the novel now it does kind of
seem
like a lot of the same [ __ ] happens
but i think it's more just like a
straight ahead like lycanthrope
story okay so the cicada angle wasn't in
it i think i mean from what i can
understand uh i think the cicada thing
was movie only i don't think that was in
the book now there was kind of like
transformation and stuff but i don't
think the book specified that he was
turning into a cicada okay which like i
said he
he didn't really look like a cicada like
that would have they never really showed
him they never really showed him when he
was fully transformed remember they just
showed him go through part of
transformation then he left
he flew out to a hole in the wall he
busted a hole through the wall and then
when they followed him
they followed his footsteps and then
they left the ground and then they found
a damn
human his human skin hanging in the
trees it looked good there's a lot of
good special effects yeah the special
effects in this are really good i think
that it's a lot better than i remembered
it i think the team that worked on this
i think they later worked on uh the fly
the david cronenberg yeah maybe as far
as yeah and i don't think that's like
fly level
it's not no no it's not like that no
more along the lines of the movie
remember piranha which was also a good
movie yeah but kind of like piranha
in terms of production quality and stuff
but yeah i mean
and we said before like this has like a
real
everybody in this is like recognizable
like i said the main guy who's like the
dad of the teenager is ronnie cox who
was obviously in beverly hills cop and
robocop total recall deliverance he was
all that baby besh it was in uh wrath of
khan she was in who's that girl and
steel magnolia is and tremors uh as well
and everybody else i recognize but i
couldn't tell you where they came from
well you got like um
one of the guys i think who do you play
the sheriff for the i can't remember but
like l q jones he was in like a lot of
sam peck and bomb movies and rg
armstrong was as well you also had don
gordon in there who was in bullet with
um steve mcqueen he was in papillon he
was in omen 3.
that was the judge right i think so yeah
and then like the other guy who i think
played the the old sheriff like with the
with the mustache yeah he that guy was
in uh walking tall right and some other
[ __ ] and this also had a very small part
one of the cops was actually played by
meshach taylor
who i recognized from designing women
that sitcom and he was in mannequin as
well he kind of like he always played
like really flamboyantly like gay
characters but he's just like plays a
cop in this one
but
so okay
let me see if i can describe like what
happens in this movie because the thing
about this movie is that i think it's
the thing that lets it down
for me was like the editing
because i think it's a little choppy
sometimes it's a little choppy and i
think i said the same thing about
communion like the editing was strange
and those are like the same director
now according to the director united
artists who released this i think they
cut out some scenes yeah so maybe
there's stuff missing definitely so
maybe i think that's why because
sometimes like stuff is like not really
explained like it'll just kind of like
go to the next thing and you're just
kind of have to like left to fill in the
blanks for me there's only one problem
with the movie i can take the choppy
edits
they they must have cut out the reason
why
dude transformed into a damn cicada that
monster just by eating bodies there
hadn't been a reason
you just can't force a person into
cannibalism and then they become a
cicada it doesn't happen
it almost sounded not even in
mississippi
there's got to be a reason there must
have been it had to have been some kind
of curse
some kind of
mississippi delta [ __ ] voodoo curse
or it had to be uh something like uh
some kind of toxic chemicals in the
ground that people were eating and then
you eat the people and it turns you into
a damn thing it has to have something to
do with you know science it has to be
science because or magic or magic one of
the two
yeah that's the kind of thing it's like
they kind of like laid it out because we
were like sitting there there's a good
idea and tom's sitting there going wait
what the [ __ ] so what okay but why is he
turning into a cicada though yeah and
then the guy's like well i'm gonna
explain it to you and he explains it i'm
like he didn't really explain it
i was like because it was just kind of
like step one step two step three blah
blah blah blah blah blah yeah and then
he's a cicada and i was just like
there's a whole bunch of stuff missing
right in there
right in there it's not you're not
really going from point a to point no it
had a lot of good elements though it did
yeah it had a lot of good elements it's
a fun movie it uh it was filmed on
location outside jackson and other
places around mississippi i was looking
at i was going
they go into a swamp and i said that
doesn't look like mississippi it looks
like louisiana
i don't know
because there there it's very rare that
you see a swamp like that anywhere in
mississippi i think that part might have
been louisiana which is you know
not far
slidell couple hours you know but uh you
could find a place like that
but you know i'm not sure if there there
might be something like that in
mississippi i just never seen it um
and then uh they got they got the
architecture correct
they got kind of like they got a lot of
things about mississippi the way it
looked back then correct
uh it
those old buildings
um
family kind of clan warfare
because the dude donald has come back as
cicada he's trying to wipe out an entire
family of people
yeah because did i also mention it's
like an intergenerational yes where
cicada monster right
so it's kind of like i said it's
complicated so it's kind of like a
kind of like a hat-filled mccoy
type situation the the movie
is a lot like pumpkin head in some ways
kind of like pumpkinhead when a pumpkin
head comes back with people that have
committed crimes and doing this and you
know like well he's like a revenge demon
if you go and like summon him and then
he'll come back and wipe out who you
want this is a revenge monster
basically taking a revenge on an entire
clan
what were they called
the [ __ ]
the kerwins the kerwins yeah was like
the family that yeah they were like all
related yeah and and
and
the dude that turns the kid that turns
into the cicada his love interest is
occurring so he's trying to save her and
kill her at the same time it's it's
kind of there was a situation like that
i think in pumpkinhead too
just kind of felt like that
danny rowling uh and i think the message
was retracted but he said yeah a guy was
forced into cannibalism in um ravenous
yeah that's true but the thing about
ravenous was that it was based on a
wendigo
you know what i mean so
i was kind of thinking like when they
just were like oh well somebody got
forced into eating dead bodies and and
then that made them a monster i was like
oh like a wendigo thing but it's not
really like a win to go thing because
wendigos don't have anything to do with
cicadas it's a mississippi win to go
which is
like a cicada maybe that's what it is
and what was funny is that it would it
would rape it would rape women and the
the the cicada monster guy would die
after and then he would be reborn his
memories
also like reincarnation kind of like
reincarnation that's what i'm saying
because cicadas right well they're like
locusts in the sense that they have like
a 17-year
uh
what did they even call that like a 17
like a live song
like
life cycle you're born as a human but
then when you're about 17 or so you
start splitting down the back and you
come out your head swells up you turn
you come out like a [ __ ]
human-sized cicada that's bipedal
and that eats people it eats people and
can pregnant women
and then you're reborn in that woman
yeah you have your memories and
everything
yeah so basically that's what happened
this is a good idea
it is i mean it's a weird and it needed
a lot of exposition because like i said
there's a lot of there's a lot of steps
that have to happen it's a mississippi
original
even though it's probably not a
mississippi dude that came up with it
it's just but that's where they put it
yeah i'm not sure like where the guy
that wrote the book well like i said the
guy that wrote the book i don't think
the cicada angle was in there it was
more like i don't know it was a werewolf
but it was kind of like a just like a
lycanthrope type of thing i probably
went down to mississippi to make the
move and they saw those cicadas and go
we gotta put these [ __ ] in the movie
let's make that let's make it like a
werewolf movie but with bugs yeah yeah
so it's like that bugs would impress
people back in those days misses every
you know mississippi bugs have pressed
the [ __ ] out of people it was like the
mekong delta literally well those bugs
are really big too yeah like sometimes
you'd be like they have because we have
them in florida too and like you'd be
like walking around out in the summer
and all of a sudden you're pulling like
one would like hit you in the face you
know what i mean they're like big and
heavy mississippi has one of the largest
populations per capita of vietnamese
immigrants because the weather's the
weather in the topography is a lot like
the mekong delta so they're right at
home there and they're fishermen
so bugs [ __ ] crazy bugs and fish
yep
but yeah so so basically what happens in
this movie is you have the mom and the
dad ronnie cox and baby bash right and
they are it starts out in 1964 right
1964. yeah and they're kind of on this
back road in millennia where their car
breaks down or whatever
and so he's like okay well you and the
dog stay in the car i'm gonna go back to
the town and get a tow truck or whatever
and she like the dog jumps out the car
so she goes into the woods in the middle
of the night like following it
and then this monster comes and like
rapes her
so
she gets pregnant from this
so then we jump ahead 17 years and
obviously they have a 17 year old son
who's been normal up to this point
but then like he suddenly gets sick and
the doctors don't know what's wrong with
him they just say it's some kind of like
a pituitary gland disorder like they
don't really know what it's like he's
dying and they don't know what the deal
is right so the parents are freaking out
what are we gonna do jackson
well yeah well they have to go back to
this what the town is called what nioba
or something like that i never heard of
mississippi yeah i don't know if they
made me sure that's a real place they
might have just made it up yeah because
they were like well we don't because bad
[ __ ] happens there so they don't want
like other people oh bad [ __ ] doesn't
happen in our town remember so it might
be that so it might just be like made up
but they're like oh well maybe it's like
they figure it's maybe some kind of
genetic disorder so like well since the
mom was raped let's try and see if we
can find out like who the dad is because
maybe we can get some answers as to
what's wrong with the kid you know if we
can find out who the rapist is right so
they have to go back to the town that
they originally went to 17 years ago and
then when he's there
like he he kind of gets a thing where
he's like really really sick but then
sometimes he's really like better and
then when he gets better he starts
sneaking out of the hospital which they
really should have like watched him
better because he just
he kept sneaking out and they'd be like
hey you snuck out and they put him back
in the hospital and then they just like
leave him alone again and he's like bye
i'm sticking out here again
so yeah so he starts like doing a
transformation thing and it's almost
kind of like
you like you said he has the same
memories yeah as the original guy who's
what was his name bobby billy connors
billy connors yeah was the rapist
but
that guy
was yeah there was some kind of thing
where he was like
yeah he slept with somebody's wife or
something like that and like he got you
slept with
the judge's cousins
he slept with his wife
he caught him
in bed
he killed the wife and then stuffed the
dude down in the damn cellar and started
starving him and then fed him the wife
and then started feeding them all the
dead bodies that were coming through the
damn
uh
through the uh the mortuary
and they hid they just put they were
buried they weren't burying people in
the cemetery they buried rocks
and they all hit it yes they're all in
on it's never really clear why they
would do that you know i mean [ __ ]
that's sticking your neck out
well that dude
was taking care of their daughter
and the daughter was the love interest
of the [ __ ] kid man it's it's
convoluted that's what i'm saying that's
very very it's very very convoluted well
when he was down in the cellar he busted
out one night back in 64.
and uh they had a breakdown on the road
and dude went to go get a tow truck they
called wrecker mississippi [ __ ] went
to go get the wrecker and when she was
waiting out the car the [ __ ]
escapee monster he'd already transformed
into some kind of cicada looking thing
he grabbed her and [ __ ] pulled her
clothes off so you get some gratuitous
teddy shots because you know that was
the time you know
teenage boys wanted to see them titties
that's where you could get them in the
movie they do it twice in the movie so
it is it is a it is a authentic
early 80s
[ __ ] horror movie okay
so then it it rapes her but it doesn't
kill her he he comes back and he find
blood all over but i don't think it was
her blood it was the blood on that damn
monster
because i guess he's peeled out through
his skin
or something something like that i don't
know it was kind of dark i couldn't tell
like what was going on she got pregnant
from it
and dude knew and they raised it and
it's the kid in the movie
all right
that [ __ ] monster died somehow they
didn't really say how he died did it i
guess it died on its own because it dies
after it has sex
yeah because that's what happens to them
so the boy was a reincarnation of that
thing
well guess what
the dude that killed him
the dude that killed the wife he had a
daughter from the wife
yeah and that ended up being the
girlfriend of the new kid so there was
kind of like he had reincarnated
so it was kind of like
this it was the daughter of his
ex-girlfriend who he ate
yeah that's weird angry this is so
complicated it's very complicated
we need like a chart yeah
i was thinking that when i was watching
well and you have to think too that
everybody in this town like kind of all
of the authority figures are all like in
on it and we're covering it up for some
reason yeah um so like the guy that like
the weirdo that um is the undertaker
like he's in on i don't think the
sheriff was in on it yeah um i don't
think he knew because he because he was
just like um younger like when the whole
[ __ ] happened but everybody else knew
like the judge and all that like
everybody knew and they were doing this
whole
thing where it was all covered up
but then
yeah so when the guy was a cicada
monster he was going around killing the
kerwins but i guess he didn't live long
enough to do it so then he raped that
woman 17 years later her teenage son
is also turned into cicada monster and
is like also wiping out kerwins yeah
so yeah so there's a lot of like small
town like conspiracy type like because
they're all in on it and nobody wants to
like tell anybody any information like
about these murderers rob jumped in and
said i want to say this movie is awesome
i don't know if that's rob levinson it
might be i don't know i think it is yeah
because i think that's his uh yeah
he likes this boob
yeah i did too and you know what i'm
amazed that i had never seen it like i
said i'd seen the transformation scenes
toward the end which are actually quite
impressive yeah um you know if you've
seen anything i think it started the
whole thing started with altered states
where they had you know they could put
those bladders like the air bladders
like underneath like people's skin and
so everybody was like want to like
transform and everything yeah so it has
like really really good effects in that
there's elements of white exploitation
in it which i liked the [ __ ] main bad
guy is [ __ ] uh just stereotypical
[ __ ]
country [ __ ] redneck for the time
almost kind of like something out of
deliverance
you know it's like that yeah which not
totally accurate but [ __ ] it was good
it's funny it's fun in the movie to see
guys like that to see characters like
that my little girl you know
running around with a shotgun wherever
he goes yeah
that checks out yeah
yeah
he's kind of like you know that's my
kind of woman
yeah what was his name uh crenshaw yeah
yeah christian he was playing himself
they said he was like the big fat guy
with the overalls with one yeah yeah no
shirt underneath yeah looking at the 70s
heidi check with their feathered hair
with their little [ __ ] there's a man
he's kind of wearing that there's a
man's kind of woman
you spit in the chat yeah it's like with
his troll
yeah so correct
but yeah so this one's not quite that
bad but because that was arkansas yeah
this is that was that that was shot in
arkansas that's where they were all from
from
yeah this is like this is a mississippi
movie so you do get like some of the
southern accents are pretty good like i
think the the the woman in the that one
office she was like overdoing in a tad
yeah but
yeah there wasn't any people from
mississippi in that movie
yeah i don't know
yeah like i said some of the accents
were too weren't too bad but yeah they
weren't annoying yeah that one woman's
was a little bit a little strong but a
little fake sounding but that's okay but
yeah i mean just
you know what i okay so i would have
liked because like i said we get to the
last scene when like the judge is
actually like saying oh okay i'm gonna
explain what's going on and he explains
like all the stuff that we just tried to
explain like i'm not sure how successful
we were and like getting across
but
i kind of wish so i was just kind of
like okay well
the guy's in the cellar
and they're feeding him dead bodies for
whatever reason
and then he turns into a cicada i was
like
i know they probably wanted to do like
the feeding him dead bodies because
maybe like i said they were going for
like a wendigo type angle because that's
kind of what that is like you you're a
cannibal and then like it turned you
into monster
which okay
um and probably they wanted some scenes
where it's like they find like all these
bodies out by the riverbank which was
actually like a good scene because like
you know a dog brings an arm and stuff
like that so that's good
but i didn't i really wish there had
been one more link in the chain that
explained why cicadas and all you had to
do it had been easy because it could go
right in with the missus with the
mississippi motif there should have been
uh like a native american guy there
all right well see i think that that one
guy was supposed to be native american
that was a guy named tom but i don't but
he didn't do any like magical indian
stuff like they have in these movies
yeah you have to have an indian in there
to indian spain
why this just happened and he had to say
something about you know burial grounds
and this and that and eating of the dead
and in this area you know the great
spirit doesn't like it and it'll turn
you into a blah blah a hot chitachi
it's like the cicada you know and it it
comes out of you so it's a win-to-go
story
basically yeah i mean that's kind of
what i thought that would have worked
but i think it would have worked better
if there had been like another
connection there like okay we we put him
in the basement and we're feeding him
corpses yeah but then like one day
um
all the cicadas came and they swarmed
right and then like he swallowed a bunch
of those or something it's like you know
what i mean i'm just i would have gone
with a native american curse
angle yeah it's like a when to go i mean
something it's a mississippi win to go
down there with all the damn bugs okay
and if you if you're a cannibal down
there that's your punishment that's what
that's all they had to do
oh okay
yeah everybody would have accepted it i
mean i mean like i said the premise is
crazy enough as it is so it's just if
you had one little thing in there yeah
it'd be like oh of course yeah some kind
of damn
indian demon goes into you
danny rowling says how many people die
in this film and are the kill scenes
good they're okay they're pretty good
okay i mean i think the transformation
scenes are the best yeah um i do like
the scene where the judge gets his head
pulled off yeah that's that's energy
yeah it's it's it's not
it the gore is on on par with like uh
friday the 13th one
which is mostly illusion you think you
saw something that didn't really happen
a little bit of that i'd say probably
about four or five people get killed
probably before the great
yeah
probably and mostly you just kind of see
like aftermath like when the one guy
gets killed because like the weirdo
that's like making hamburgers and like
has the guy in there like i'm gonna make
you some hamburgers
like with his stained wife beater on and
it's like so
the cicada guy like kind of like chews
on his neck a little bit but then like
you mostly just see him like dead like
with just like blood and i was like when
the movie started i was surprised how
good the score is
it's got a pretty good score now it's
mostly incidental in the movie but the
the intro and outro music was effective
it's uh spooky sound especially for the
time i found out now that you mentioned
i'm glad you mentioned that because uh
the guy that did the score was named les
baxter
and he was kind of like a big band type
of guy like back in the old days he also
did the scores for all the roger corman
edgar allan poe movies okay like pitt
and the pendulum and all that okay and
he did beach blanket bingo okay
so there's that too and i was just like
i'm glad i wrote that down because i was
like oh that's neat but the movie's on
amazon it's got no reviews nobody knows
about this movie
i kind of feel yeah i found like a few
reviews of it
um i think that
there has been like kind of a nice
blu-ray released of it in like 2014 and
i think
that
tom holland like a few years ago was
talking about maybe remaking it because
it didn't come out the way he wanted it
exactly
um but i don't know like i haven't heard
anything about that like for a few years
but he was like throwing around the idea
it could be fixed you'd have to keep you
you keep the segata gig
thing i would keep that
i would too but i would explain it i
yeah i would explain it a little bit
better and make the monster look more
like a cicada i mean you could do the
technology back then you could do well
didn't don't like um didn't the ancient
egyptians didn't they have um like a god
that looked kind of like a big bug like
a big scarab or something like capri
isn't his name yeah i don't know like i
think he had something like that so
there's like a precedent for it you
could even go like the franz kafka
metamorphosis direction like the guy
that wakes up in bed and he's a giant
cockroach you know what i mean yeah so i
think i would go with for the fly
angle make it kind of like a fly
i guess now that we're talking about it
david cronenberg's the fly that guy he
didn't really look like a fly either
[Laughter]
until like all his skin like rushed it
off i'd do it like that
but
i mean all practical effects and puppets
yeah
i mean yeah it's going to like look a
lot better i just wish that
like if they remake it i think they
should just make him look a little bit
more
insect-like yeah that's all
yeah maybe give him something you know
maybe give him like some weird because
don't cicadas have like this big red
yeah eyes like that so the movie's
credit when i was 15 watching this
sitting on the couch just [ __ ]
stoned as hell [ __ ] trying to
stabilize the room watching this
i was
very forgiving of it because i didn't
really understand the cicada angle i
thought it was an alien
yeah you know it just kind of looks like
just like a monster it looks good
yeah but it didn't like it didn't like
scream cicadas you know
so i think if you're gonna remake it
like like i said the transformation is
good like i really liked it's real goopy
and
like
[ __ ]
like looking at it from between [ __ ]
you know
oh man did you see that [ __ ] you know
that's the way
yeah you didn't have the same tolerance
back then in the in the early 80s
that's true you know i mean it's still i
mean you can tell it's 1982 but for 1982
it's pretty good i mean the yeah like
the facial effects like look pretty good
it looks like pretty just on the
stepping stone to better movies like the
fly
yeah you know some of the other
and you can see that it kind of feels in
some places like uh
that transformation scene was a little
bit like something out of the evil dead
a little bit
kinda and uh well now
and american werewolf in london it you
can see a little bit of that in it it's
just it was just building up to that
i mean american werewolf in london i
feel like was like the gold standard
yeah i mean actually probably still is
that that transformation werewolf
transformation still looks fantastic
hey that was 81. 81 okay so it was
before this that was 81. okay yeah um it
still looks good yeah so you know um oh
i wanted to say too isn't it weird i was
like i didn't realize this until i saw
another review of this and i was like
reading some of the comments and they
said you know in the early 1980s there
were an awful lot of monster rape movies
oh yeah like you had in seminoid and
yeah humanoids from the d yeah uh extra
it was sex and violence combined
yeah and what was that what was that
other one uh galaxy of terror yeah with
the big warrantless lion worm like that
was one of them better [ __ ] um i
think we reviewed that didn't we we
reviewed that
i think we did yeah like roger corman
yeah there was so i was just like yeah i
guess so there's like a lot of monster
rape because there's two there's two
monster rapes that's how you got teenage
guys to come see a movie back in the
prep a monster raping a woman and we get
to see your titties yeah
yeah it was pretty
it was pretty easy access to porn yeah
so you know your friends come back to
the movies oh man i saw that one that
was good man this and that and the
[ __ ] the the the the big worm raped
that chick she was fine too man big
teddy's going oh we're going to see that
one that's that's what it was
wait wait they should just put that on
the poster
all right
you see titties and a woman gets raped
by a giant word everybody's like sold
it wasn't just american teenagers man
the italians teenagers were even worse
yeah you know the italians were even
worse about that this way it was
yeah it should be that way that's the
way it's supposed to be that does get
people to [ __ ] see a movie it's a
cheap shot but yeah it sells it sells
movie tickets sometimes it's just funny
it sells movie tickets to on a b movie
yeah on a b movie it sells tickets well
yeah because that's kind of one of the
selling yeah yeah
the funny thing about it though is that
a lot of those movies like you know the
rape scenes or the gore scenes or
something like that maybe amount to
maybe five or ten minutes in the whole
movie and then like the rest of it
you're just kind of like sitting there
well actually like the rape scene might
only be a few dozen frames that's what
i'm saying yeah
because you can't i mean both both times
without getting it i mean both times it
happens in the dark like you can tell
what's happening and you can see the
boobs and stuff there's suggestions but
it's mostly a suggestion you can't
really because i'm just like ooh that's
kind of like i don't know but yeah so
it never showed that thing on her
it showed her laying down and then it
panned as it was coming it was coming
towards her and then it just showed her
moving well and it and it showed her him
like the monster like tearing her
clothes she showed that but then it just
showed her shaking back and forth yeah
and that's it like
that yeah
and i was like oh
that's what's going on
well didn't it um
it says on the wikipedia page that she
got
happy thermometer hypothermia because
even though it was mississippi yeah it
was in the wintertime it was cold yeah i
guess it was like
yeah i think it was like winter early
spring yeah and so she had to lay out
there naked for like however long it
took to shoot the [ __ ] [ __ ] and she
got hypothermia there yeah cold in
mississippi is 50.
50 40. i mean it can it can get down to
freezing
sometimes that's that's like a really
bad winter though you'll see little
icicles but it never snows really that's
what i'm saying it's just i mean it's
kind of like florida it's like it
doesn't really snow every once every 15
years maybe yeah and it's like yeah
it'll go down to like in the 30s like
every like maybe once or twice a year
but that's about it right but i don't
know but that's they said she got
hypothermia so it must have been like
unusual
yeah crazy but yeah so
i'm actually kind of like um glad that
you recommended this yes i don't because
i thought i was like oh well maybe i saw
it because i knew like the the
transformation scenes looked familiar
but i had never i had never seen it and
it was like kind of cool because like i
said you get to see like the first tom
holland writing credit and
got to see like spot the character actor
everybody that was in it yeah but yeah
it was a lot of fun and it's a crazy
story it's just crazy yeah you gotta pay
3.99 to see it on on amazon prime but
it's it's it's it's a good watch i liked
it yeah it's like a fun if you really
like like early 80s just like kind of
crazy yeah bat [ __ ] insane and the
movie's taking itself seriously it's not
it's not yeah it's not horny or zany
it's not trying to be funny or anything
it's it's uh
it's it's trying to be kind of like uh
american werewolf in london and [ __ ]
piranha and what else would you compare
it to in terms of tone totally yeah it
really didn't have any kind of like
comic relief kind of [ __ ] in it which
was interesting at the time we watched
it we thought it was pretty hardcore we
thought it was like an underground kind
of slasher type movie something you
really weren't supposed to be watching
back in you know when we saw it at like
15 we're like what have some serious
[ __ ]
and it turned into a cicada that's
[ __ ] up yeah
yeah up there with like friday the 13th
one two and three you know we thought it
was like that
yeah halloween three which i liked
yeah that definitely got a real kinda
like that it kind of like it was it was
harder than extra heart more hardcore
than extro although i will admit and i'm
going to do a video um i actually did a
video about extro that's going up for my
new channel like later on this month
that movie if you haven't seen that is
weird as [ __ ] yeah it's one of the toy
soldiers that were shooting people and
stuff right
yeah
among many other things that wasn't even
what the movie was about no the little
eggs it's an alien baby yeah it's weird
it is
way way out there yeah it's it's extra
is probably uh
a better movie but i think this is more
violent than extra i think it's been a
long time since i've seen it i don't
know because i remember extra has a
scene where a full-grown man uh climbs
out of a woman's vagina i remember that
yes
so
that was weird so if that's your thing
because irish movie wouldn't it it was
yeah british movie yeah it had some
pretty uh messed up [ __ ] and it was
pretty weird right
but the one that [ __ ] the king of
them all back in the day back in these
days the ones that would really [ __ ] us
up was the brood and video drone
chronicling well yeah those are [ __ ]
weird man well because those just like
the the ideas of them were just like so
[ __ ]
yeah
he came up with some bizarro ass [ __ ]
i mean you know
hard hard to compete with that
all right so i guess we're gonna wrap it
up
so tomorrow like i said uh we will be
back talking about amityville 2 the
possession which is kind of loosely
based on
the defeo murders but they changed
nobody's name and stuff like that yeah
but
had that girl from last american virgin
in it with the damn mole on her head
that cutie dan franklin her name yeah
yeah she was also in that movie with
john cusack he's better off dead yeah
she played like a french girl in it
takes her clothes off as always
well not well she did in this but um she
didn't in i don't remember her i think
she didn't last american football she
did yeah i'm pretty sure she was naked
in that but i was saying like in the
john cusack one better after yeah i
don't think she was naked in that yes
her job was to show bq to take her
clothes off she could act though
she could act yeah
i always liked her i always thought she
was great but yeah all right so we'll be
talking about that tomorrow so everybody
have a good rest of your weekend have a
good fourth of july if you have the day
off tomorrow and we'll be back tomorrow
evening to talk about another movie
bye